well you may have seen a lot of growth
over in the southwest valley businesses
they're just booming expanding off the
south decatur and the 215 and it's the
late and the latest addition there well
it's a new hotel mary jane belliesa
shares the area's progress
expect loud noise and construction in
the southwest valley as nigro
construction assembles a new hotel off
decatur in 215 spring hill suites by
marriott will feature more than 120
rooms a 24-hour gym meeting spaces and
more the president of niagara
construction says the new spot will
support the growing number of visitors
there's a definite need for this
location
to have business people be able to stay
who service the industrial in the area
industrial has been off the charts and
the 215 corridor southwest corridor is
an amazing place to be spring hill
suites will join other businesses in the
growing southwest area including
starbucks and dottie's gaming lounge the
project is expected to be completed in
early 2023 latin chamber president peter
guzman says this project is a big asset
in providing jobs for our community it
could have been very easily for these
this family the niagara construction
group to
you know hold off and wait till covet
passes before taking the risk of
actually doing construction
but you know what thank god they did
they just pushed forward they kept
people working and that's why we're
excited andrew levitt moved to russell
and grand canyon last year and is
excited to see the new building and now
it's just this booming and up and coming
i mean it's very affordable compared to
most other parts of vegas you know
summerlin and henderson
and now they're building that new
station casinos and they got the whole
tech center that's coming in on durango
it's
it's cool reporting from decatur and
sunset mary jean valeza live local now